we begin this morning with the narrowing
hunt for the Trump administration
official who wrote that highly critical
op-ed article in The New York Times the
White House reportedly has a short list
of who it might be
this comes after President Trump called
on Attorney General Jeff Sessions to
launch an investigation meanwhile the
New York Times is promising to keep the
writers identity a secret the newspaper
released a statement reading in part
quote the president's threats both
underscore why we must safeguard the
identity of the writer of this op-ed and
serve as a reminder of the importance of
a free and independent press to American
democracy Molla linky joins us now from
the White House with more molla good
morning
well good morning as speculation swirls
about who was behind this scathing piece
more than two dozen officials including
the vice president have come out denying
they wrote it meanwhile President Trump
has escalated his attacks on its author
and on Bob Woodward for his critical new
book on the Trump administration the
president calling Woodward an idiot and
his book a work of fiction
totally phony quotes I've been totally
like fraudulent books in South Dakota
Friday night president Trump continued
to blame what he called lousy libel laws
for the scathing allegations in Bob
Woodward's new book fear Trump in the
White House create some libel laws that
when people say stuff bad about you you
can sue them and if you're right you win
would you do would you please would you
please do that then you see books that
would be really like Kay Trump has done
a great job earlier in an interview mr.
Trump said it's only a matter of time
before the White House figures out the
identity of the anonymous official who
claims to be part of a resistance within
the administration when you first saw
this New York Times piece in your gut
who's the first person that came to your
head well I could think of four or five
mostly people that either I don't like
or respect the fact is that we'll find
this person he believes it's somebody in
national security speaking to reporters
aboard Air Force One President Trump
said he wants the Department of Justice
to open an investigation
[Music]
because I really believe it's national
security top administration officials
have come out in full force denying they
were behind the op-ed including United
Nations ambassador nikki Haley who wrote
one of her own calling the writer
cowardly and anti-democratic because
really what they've done is virtually
you know it's treason some Republican
lawmakers disagreed they would go down
far it's not treason under the law
it's disloyalty it is cowardly House
Republican leader Kevin McCarthy said in
a letter to the editor to the New York
Times that the official should be
exposed and fired the Department of
Justice has declined to comment
Anthony mola leggy at the White House
thanks mullah